So a good Just Cause
is not for any
particular group of people.
It is idealized
in the sense that anyone who
believes in that vision of the
future is invited to join.
So if you believe all
people are created equal and that's
the world you want to live in, join
the Cause.
If you believe my Just Cause it's,
I imagine, a world in which the vast
majority of people wake up
every single morning inspired,
feel safe wherever they are,
and end the day fulfilled by the
work that they do.
If that appeals to you, then join
our Cause.
And it doesn't, it doesn't
leave anyone out.
So that's, so it has to be
inclusive.
It has to be stated in a
way that anyone who wants to build
that world could build that world.
A Just Cause must be for
others, not for yourself.
There's no such thing as a Just
Cause for me, right?
The world that you hope to benefit,
the company, the world that you hope
to build, the company you hope to
build, the family you hope to build
is for others, it's so that others
may enjoy it.
And I think this mistake is made a
lot, especially when companies
articulate their visions.
It's about them.
To be
the best, to be the most respected,
to be the, you know, whatever it is.
That that benefits no one else
but you.
And
a Just Cause must be to the benefit
of others.
Idealistic is the easy
one, which is stated in
terms that are literally
unachievable.
So idealistic is the fun one.
If you make it achievable, well,
then it's just a goal and it's a
milestone and it's not truly
a Just Cause.
So yeah, idealism is essential.
So resilient is different than
stable, because stable
is like if a ship
is stable, you know it goes into the
storm and it comes out of the storm.
And it survived the storm.
But it's still the same ship, right?
Stable companies survive things,
but they're still the same companies.
Resilience is the ability to adapt
and change and a resilient
organization, a resilient family.
A resilient family goes into
tragedy, the loss of a loved one,
you know, the sudden loss of a loved
one and they come out
different.
They come through that stronger
people.
Resilient organizations have
gone into the pandemic
and their
cultures are different.
They've adapted,
they're stronger, their
relationships are more intense.
And so resilience is the ability to
adapt and
grow and strengthen, not just
be so filled with concrete
that you just make it through
something.
Well, Just Causes is
about idealism.
It's about imagining a future, a
future that doesn't exist
right now.
So in the United States, we have a
declaration of independence in which
the founding fathers have said they
imagine a world in which all men are
created equal.
All people are equal,
endowed with unalienable rights,
amongst which include life, liberty
and the pursuit of happiness.
Now we're clearly not there,
but it is a striving.
It is a pursuit.
And by the way,
we'll never get there, but we'll die
trying.
Or Martin Luther King, who imagined
a world very different to the one he
grew up in.
We're still not there
and but we'll die trying.
And the milestones that we pass,
whether it's legislative or
civil rights or gay rights or
women's suffrage, you know, these
are stepping stones that
prove to us that we're moving in the
right direction and
having a Just Cause a sense of a
future state that we're working
towards is what gives our lives
and our work meaning.
It's, I think, important to
note that the women's
suffrage movement in the United
States, that every
single founder, every single
founder of the women's suffrage move
in the United States died before
the first woman ever voted.
Now, do you think they felt like
their lives were failures?
No, of course not.
It's because they could see the
growing movement.
They could see the
momentum, they could see that they
were moving closer and closer
towards their vision.
Would they'd like to have done to
how to go quicker, of course.
But they could see that others took
their torch and promised to carry it
for them after they died and their
Cause was no longer there as it
became the Cause of others.
And to have a sense
of Just Cause means that
it doesn't belong to any one of us,
but it becomes all of ours.
And that's what gives us the
confidence and we can all lie on our
deathbeds and say, "I'm passing
something on."
By the way,
this is a big deal in families.
This is why families have legacies.
And this is why carrying our last
name matters
because there are those who came
before us and we want to honor those
who came before us.
We don't want to
let them down.
We don't let their sacrifices
go in vain.
And so having a Just Cause and
feeling a part of something bigger
than ourselves is what gives
our lives and our work and all of
these things legacy.
And there's good data to show
that when we have a sense of our
past, it actually makes
us better equipped to make decisions
for the future.
It's ironic, you know, you hear
politicians all the time say, "You
know, we're doing this for our
children."
Well, if we invoked
our children every time we made
decisions, we make a lot better
decisions than most of us do.
But if you invoke the past,
it actually makes us better because
as I said before, to see ourselves
not at the beginning of a process,
but in the middle of it, and
that we have responsibility to the
past and we have a responsibility
to ensure that we can pass
it on after our passing,
lots of passes in there.
It is actually makes us better
equipped to make better long term
decisions.